[Music]
after a tick-tock video went viral
showing a sonogram from what seems like
zendaya's account zendaya is clearing up
rumors that she's pregnant who knows the
world may never know
well now we know she quickly shut down
fans speculating that she's expecting a
child with boyfriend tom holland the
actress wrote on her instagram story see
now this is why i stay off twitter just
making stuff up for no reason but the
actress isn't too focused on the rumors
swirling she's busy on set for her new
movie zendaya added anyway back to
filming challengers
fans have been falling for the new prank
on tiktok where you get hashtag crist
viewers watch a fake story then kris
jenner pops up proving it's all a hoax
still the prank has many on twitter
fooled even lilna's ex reacted to the
fake baby news the rapper responded
writing i hate twitter because i'm
sitting here about to congratulate
zendaya via dm about a baby that doesn't
exist
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there tom and zadea who
co-star and spider-man no way home have
famously been private about their
romance i just feel very lucky but the
pair gives a little glimpse of their
relationship on social media zendaya
posted this sweet birthday shout out to
tom writing happiest of birthdays to the
one who makes me the happiest
and zendaya and tom aren't shy about
showing love on the gram back in
september tom shared a tribute to z for
her 25th birthday with the cutest pick
of the pair with tom in his spidey suit
very sweet post from tom what was it
like to see the post and i noticed you
commented calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know
um um yeah no i um i appreciated you
know the love that i got from my loved
ones and then also from you know the
world it was i felt incredibly loved and
grateful for for all of that so you know
i have no complaints it was a great
birthday and now i'm here so
not bad
when tom's not playing spider-man he's
supporting the euphoria star when she's
taking a break from channeling her
character root i think it's great to
have that support and that love around
you because you need that you know this
isn't an easy easy job so it's good to
have
that to to free you up from it every now
and then
[Music]